There's no way. There's no shot. That's just a nonsensical thing
to say. >> I just don't understand Hatch having this argument.
>> If you believe that, you are a mark, okay? Who amongst
us hasn't in their youth got, uh, you know, literal Nazi
>> Yeah, that's the worst thing ever. I think that's That
is like the worst thing you could say about a person.
>> New damage control memo from Grand Platter campaign
says they've seen some of the strongest fundraising of the entire
campaign in the past few days and have a new poll in the field
yesterday plus today showing him leading Collins. Per sources,
Grand Platter's campaign is now aware of the severity of the
next round of information that will come out. Worse than Nazi
tattoo. Worse than Reddit. Worse than Predators Paradise. The
emergency trip home had nothing to do with reporters at the house
his dad gave him. This is the Defcon 1 of damage
So, some people are arguing about all this Some people are arguing
that like, oh, it's pretty obvious that he's trying to do damage
control ready and there's a new allegation coming out and it's
all It's all a big It's all like a huge
Okay, just in Maine US Senate candidate Grand Platter Grand Platter's
campaign is reportedly panicking as bombshell new information
is about to come out even worse than everything we've known so
far. Maine wire. Brutal. They're rushing to prepare more damage
control. Cook him. Maybe hold some until after the general election
to help Susan Collins get a major surge after he's the official
Okay, so then
there was a Wall Street Journal article that came out today.
Wall Street Journal exclusive with Grand the Platter with Grand
Platter talking to
Democratic officials, like actual Democratic Democrat senators.
I believe Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren were a part of
the group he talked to. Let me just go grab my
article here. Beep beep beep beep. So, this is today, earlier
today, 5:00 Eastern, so only, you know, 6 hours ago or something.
Senators privately asked Platter whether new allegations will
emerge. Maine Senate candidate tells Democratic lawmakers the
worst of the rumors we've all heard are not true.
In private meeting Tuesday with some Dem Senate Democrats, Maine
Senate candidate Garam Plater attempted to quell growing concerns
from some in the party that a string of negative revelations
about his life had jeopardized his candidacy.
Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders asked Plater if any of the additional
allegation if any additional allegations would emerge against
the embattled Democratic candidate, according to people familiar
with the discussion. Plater said there weren't any. Massachusetts
Senator Elizabeth Warren, who also attended the meeting, followed
up and said there is a big difference between marital issues
and allegations of assault, the people said. Plater agreed and
denied any credible allegations of assault were forthcoming.
"It's not a secret I've had a messy complicated life," he told
the senators. One of the people said, "The worst of the rumors
we've all heard are not true." The meeting with some of Plater's
biggest supporters in the Senate, Sanders and Warren have both
endorsed him, ended with most of the group continuing to express
support express support for the neophyte politician. The gathering
also underscored that Plater's campaign had entered crisis mode.
Over the weekend, the Wall Street Journal reported Plater engaged
in sexually explicit texts with other women while married, prompting
concerns among Democrats that his personal life would imperil
the party's shot at flipping one of the most one of the Senate's
most competitive seats.
"I have no idea if more shoes will drop," Senator Peter Welch,
Democrat Vermont, said a day after attending the Asked if Plater
had been reassuring, Welch said he was very explicit that he
accepts the right of Maine voters to ask him questions about
his personal life and his responsibility to answer those
Others who attended the meeting said he they remained convinced
Plater was the right candidate. "I didn't go in needing reassurance
and I felt I left feeling confident," said Senator Tina Smith,
Democrat Minnesota, who described herself as excited about Plater's
candidacy.
Plater met with senators Tuesday at the headquarters of the Senate
Democrats campaign arm in Washington. He also met privately with
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer, Democrat New York, who
had supported his Democratic opponent the primary opponent rather,
Maine Governor Janet Mills before she dropped out in April. A
Platner campaign official said the candidate had productive meetings
focused on making the best case against Maine incumbent GOP Senator
Susan Collins. The official said senators offered to lend their
support to the campaign.
Later Tuesday, Platner attended a fundraiser with Ron Klain,
who was the chief of staff to President Joe Biden, who also was
to attend a fundraiser in Washington with Vote Vets, a Democratic
organization that had has endorsed his candidacy. But he abruptly
headed back to Maine Tuesday night when he learned of reporters
staking out his in-laws' house and his family's restaurant, the
campaign official said. Although the party is still publicly
standing by Platner, his efforts haven't allayed concerns for
many 1 week before the state's primary, the results of which
are expected to make him the Democratic nominee.
Platner has said in past interviews he has nothing else to disclose,
only to be the subject of another round of critical stories about
his past behavior and comments. Rumors of additional stories
with allegations of misconduct have been circulating in conversations
between Democratic lawmakers, staffers, and activists in recent
days. Many Democrats have have uncomfortably gotten behind Platner
because he is expected he is the expected nominee in one of the
nation's most competitive Senate races. Maine, which former Vice
President Kamala Harris won by almost 7 points in 2024,
is one of the Democrats' best pick-up opportunities and the key
to their chances of recapturing a Senate majority this midterm.
I'm I'm literally making things up. Sorry, I'm not like reading
it perfectly. Whether you like him or "he is who we have to support,"
Amanda Litman, co-founder of Democratic recruitment and training
organization Run for Something, said in a video posted Monday
on X. "Is Grant Platner a perfect person? No, but he is better
than Susan Collins and we've got to help him win." His campaign
sent out a memo Wednesday projecting strength. It included new
polling from a progressive organization conducted after the journal's
reporting Saturday that Platner had engaged in sexually explicit
That poll had him leading Collins by 4 percentage points. The
memo also said Platner's fundraising was up this week. Across
the board, the poll numbers, the fundraising, the conversations
with voters, all signs point in our favor, the memo reads. Comments
posted on Platner's now deleted Reddit account have included
playing down assault and crude posts about sex workers and
He also previously admitted to having covered up a Nazi-linked
tattoo.
Platner also had an active account on Kik, a popular private
messaging app, as of earlier this week. Platner's profile showed
a mirror selfie of him shirtless with a towel wrapped around
his waist. Many of his tattoos were clearly visible. The journal
verified the account on the app, a messaging platform that has
been widely used for
There's no way.
There's no shot.
There's no shot that this is real.
>> Bet to flip flip >> This guy's the best bet to
flip flip a Senate seat. >> We don't know. We don't know
if he actually is. The far left thinks he is. The far left thinks
that the populism is going to work. >> The far left thinks
he is. That How did the far left thinking Shahikot was going
to win in San Francisco work out for him? Turns out what the
far left thinks doesn't mean jack compared to what voters think.
The voters think he's the best chance. The voters are the people
who want him there. Come on, man. >> work, but it's a very
moderate state. So, I don't I don't know if that's true.
some some seats don't need to be
>> This needs to be flipped. This one needs to be flipped,
but not by him.
>> Some seats don't need to be flipped.
Even Klein's a [__] Cool. So, I mean, not that we
needed more evidence. Listen, some seats don't need to be flipped.
A Republican majority in the Senate isn't that big a deal, actually.
>> There's still other other Democrats in the race. >> No,
listen.
Let me ask you this. Does his opponent have any Nazi imagery
on him?
neither the Democrats, cuz this is the primary, so the Democrats
that I have seen do not know. They do not. >> So I like
them better. >> Yeah, there's still a chance that one of
them can win. >> And then there's the incumbent does the
incumbent have any Nazi
>> Not that I know of. >> What about fascist affiliations?
>> Not that I >> him better, too, already.
>> Yeah. I mean, literally literally just
Instantly
with
showing that showing his ass showing he knows nothing about politics.
Well, I like him I like him better, then. Well, it's actually
a woman and you just don't know that, so
I mean, okay. Talking out of his ass
No, it's he's not even a Susan Collins defender. He doesn't know
who Susan Collins is, right? He He likes the guy who's the current
incumbent in Maine better. I I have a bit of a reaction from
top Republican
influencer. All right, top Republican oppo researcher right here.
>> How do you How is the timestamp literally coming in
and it's >> All right, there it is. >> All right,
there. >> Okay, we'll start right about here. >> This
is him reviewing some more of >> the fact that Susan Collins
has been there for 30 years and in those 30 years everything
got harder down here. 30 years. She's chair of appropriations.
She likes to tell us all that she has this immense amount of
power. She brings all this money into the state of Maine. Why
then is housing becoming entirely unaffordable for younger folks
in the state? Why are we seeing the actual
30 years.
She's chair of appropriations. She likes to tell us all that
she has this immense amount of power. She brings all this money
into the state of Maine. Why then is housing becoming entirely
unaffordable for younger folks in the Why are we seeing the actual
collapse
>> heart shatters. There's screenshots of Dubie's Discord
logs bringing about asking Hassan to push push a tweet that he
still ended up getting ratioed into oblivion lol. >> collapse
of our rural health care system right now. She has been in charge
for 30 years and she has overseen a system that has brought us
to the brink of collapse. >> You talk about the the culture
of attacking in in right now. I mean, those who are criticizing
you are going
your history, right? Online. Wrote a post that have been deleted
but did say racist things. A lot of people were like, his political
aspirations are dead. This campaign is over. >> Well, what
you don't understand is I don't really have political aspirations.
I mean, I didn't get into this because I want to be a politician.
I got into this
>> This is the one time Hutch might have the appropriate
face, okay?
I I didn't I don't really have political
[__] you're running for the Senate. Come on, man.
>> I believe in building a different kind of politics for
working folks. >> So, I guess what my question
>> I mean, I don't even understand that. I don't have any
political aspirations. That just doesn't make any sense.
That's just a nonsensical thing to say. >> And this is
is why you think voters chose to eat >> I'll give it that.
That's like ah, shucks. He's playing into his character, >> you
for those posts?
>> Ah, shucks. I don't know about politics. I was just
going to grab them there oysters,
you know? >> Or look the other way. >> Well, I think
it's mostly forgiveness.
Because when I explained it, I just pointed out that look, I've
not always been who I am today.
I mean, I was a young man who spent the bulk of my 20s in intense
combat zones. I grew up in the infantry. And that was my lived
experience. I left that world with many of the kind of cultural,
I would say, um, elements that come out of it. I mean, the the
infantry is a place of hyper-masculinity. It's a place of intense
violence. Things that are seen as virtues there are generally
not seen as virtues in the normal world. And then [snorts] I
had to struggle with how do I
>> You see how he's like that's the thing that's like almost
spooky about him is anybody who's operated in that world like
99% of people who operate in that
can't articulate
the problems with it and how that how that like interacts with
when they come back to the mainland when they leave those combat
zones.
Like everybody who actually goes and experiences these things
can't come back and articulate
why it them up why certain things that they thought were cool
or important or or really good might not be accepted in mainstream
society. They they couldn't articulate it this well.
That's what's kind of spooky about him to me cuz I I feel like
it's weird cuz I I totally get people who are like patriotic
and they don't have like a lot going on upstairs and they just
want to go and they just want to fight and that's like the thing
they're into. And they don't have a lot there's just not a lot
there. For somebody who does have a lot there that that's like
a totally different animal to me and I don't know I don't know
how to interact with that or think about it. >> come out
of that and integrate
>> that he also needs this class of person like the war
culture type person. I don't hate it.
Yeah yeah I don't hate it. I just it's cool that he can explain
it. It just feels like a totally different kind of animal to
me versus like a regular politician. Although maybe like I get
my hackles up listening to him talk about combat and
But I'm sure like realistically my hackles should be up listening
to almost any politician. Like I'm sure they're all playing a
character they're all like lying to some extent right? So when
he's doing this it's like I can it's just more obvious to me.
And it's it's a little weird to that there's like a dissonance
going on in my brain that makes it difficult to listen >> great back
into society.
And and I talked about that journey. I talked about it very very
honestly and I think a lot of people recognize that the ability
to transform
the ability to change
is kind of just a normal human trait. I mean, I don't think there
are a lot of Americans that want the world to think that everything
they ever said when they were 25.
>> Hutch, by the way, Hutch literally agrees with this
bar for bar. This is like Hutch's worldview precisely. Anybody
who's been to like addiction counseling or any sort any form
of like addiction treatment will think of the world this way.
So, I don't know how Hutch can come out and criticize this guy,
to be honest >> are forever.
And I don't think anybody believes that's how people work. So,
that's why. I mean, I think as I got I went around the state
of Maine and I talked about it publicly. I talked about it with
everybody who lives >> I also don't know if Hutch is paying
>> And I would answer every question that came up with
the >> be paying attention right now. >> Ironically,
you know, we don't really talk about it much here in Maine anymore.
The only time it ever >> The first
The first story that came out was the Reddit posts and
I remember saying at the time like that's not enough for me to
not support him in the primary. And And I think he's probably
right that a lot of people are yearning for that kind of politician
because it it comes across as more authentic, you know? It was
after the tattoo that I started to waver a bit. But the Reddit
post alone, I was like, "Ah, these are not great, a lot of these,
but it wouldn't be disqualifying for me in the primary."
Uh Lord Darian, thank you so much for the primer. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> comes up is when journalists come in from
the outside or when I leave Maine. Then people want to talk about
>> But it also still comes up with your own party. I mean,
just a few days ago, Congressman Jake Auchincloss said the tattoo
that was once on your chest that you've now covered up that resembles
a Nazi SS symbol should be disqualifying and he wants Maine voters
to agree with him, meaning not choose >> Right. So, I guess
>> Like I think the appropriate answer to this would be
to validate the concerns of Americans.
They're like, "Listen, I understand. It's a rough spot, you know,
you you can stick to your obvious
story that you you know, you only found out it was a Nazi tattoo,
you know, like 4 weeks ago or whatever." >> Okay, we'll
see. I guess I think
I could totally see Platter validating that concern, right? I
could totally see him saying, "I understand how that's concerning
to people and you know, like I said, I didn't know what it was
when I got it, blah blah blah blah blah."
But he could easily just say, "Yeah, I understand why that concerns
people." >> I think the smart political answer to a question
like this would be like, "Listen, I put myself in the shoes of
a American, I understand that he doesn't do that. He does this.
He goes a different way with it with his >> covered up
that resembles a Nazi SS symbol should be disqualifying and he
wants Maine voters to agree with him, meaning not choose >> Right,
so I guess he wants to choose Susan Collins. Interesting choice
for a Democrat. One, Zakim lives in Massachusetts Massachusetts,
so I'm not going to I'm not actually all that worried about what
he thinks.
Also, what's disqualifying for the record is the fact that uh
Susan Collins has not represented the people of Maine. The fact
that we are seeing our healthcare system collapse in the state.
That's disqualifying.
I you know, >> Okay, so he does go a different way.
Did Hudge watch this or I'm curious. >> What other people
think about me not in the state of Maine, what establishment
Democrats think about me, that's that's their business. Uh it's
very clear >> It's a defiant kind of posture that I that
I just I have such contempt for. >> that here in the state
of Maine, the
>> Listen, if people want to get their panties in a twist
I
I mean,
to me, I think you want Dems to win. If Dems try if his strategists
are telling him this is the tone you should strike,
I do understand him like
I do understand him trying to strike that tone. It would depend
on how much he's trying to avoid accountability for his own actions.
Do you know what I >> About a little Totenkopf tattoo.
You know.
Who amongst us hasn't uh in their youth got uh you know, literal
Nazi tattoos. People want to whine and complain about that. Americans
want to get so uptight about I just hate that I have such contempt
for this this kind of reaction to people having I would say very
rational concerns about
very obvious problems. >> Really do >> I Like I Dude,
>> it's so hard to watch this and not just point out you
pretended to not understand what Connor was saying. You did this
kind of reaction to Connor when he raised a a valid concern.
And you did it for not even close At least he's lying for the
sake of like Dems possibly retaking the Senate. What are you
lying for? What are you lying to yourself? What are you lying
to your audience for?
>> Understand that I am Let him without the Totenkopf >> cast
the first stone. >> Yeah. Who I claim to be? Uh I'm a very
real person and warts and all. And and I've talked about it and
I will continue to talk about it and they seem to
Yeah. If if people if people in the Democratic Party uh in other
states don't like me, that's not really my problem. >> The
one thing that I heard from regular people who were trying to
figure out whether they believed you specifically about this
tattoo. Cuz you said I didn't know what it was. Like I put a
skull and bones on my chest in 2007.
You've also described yourself as a as a military history buff.
And their question is how did he not know if if he is a military
history buff? >> Because that motif
>> I have seen on French Foreign Legion
>> I have seen it on US Special Forces ODAs. I've seen
on other Marines. It's a that skulls and crossbones of a myriad
of kind of kind of versions are for fairly obvious reasons incredibly
popular. It >> Completely non-responsive, by the way.
Does anybody notice that? I mean, obviously he's practiced this
And he I would assume he's on a bit of autopilot here. Obviously,
his team
>> Wait. Okay, it's
He's saying that he's giving a reason for why he wouldn't have
known what it
Is that not Is that non-responsive? >> prepped him for
these questions.
But completely non-responsive. Why are you as a self-proclaimed
history buff who was in a Reddit thread commenting about the
Totenkopf?
There's a thread of him.
There's a Reddit post from him in a thread s- specifically about
the Totenkopf. Um >> in combat units throughout history.
So, it's a the I That's why. And for the
>> You By the way, you can't see the Totenkopf anywhere
in the thread.
Right? You literally can't see it on the on the the picture that's
in that Reddit thread, it is about a Totenkopf ostensibly, but
you can't even see it on the soldier in the picture that accompanies
the thread.
You literally can't see it at all. >> I re-enlisted in
the United States Army. >> I got screened for gang and
hate
>> I worked for the State Department. I had a top secret
clearance. I was on the ambassador to Afghanistan's security
>> Well, I think that makes me a little bit concerned about
our screening process, you know? Like, I think we've This is
like a mythos discovering a day zero
Uh well, maybe the government should add the Totenkopf to the
list of problematic tattoos. That's a bit concerning to me. Tweak
with 100 knock, do you think embracing Platner could bring some
people who felt like they were exiled by the purity testing before?
Like saying people aren't beyond redemption or do you think he's
dishonest?
I know he's dishonest. That's the thing. I you know, there could
be some merit to what you're saying. But that requires real honesty.
And we know that he's lying. And fine, you could argue it's the
best choice for him to make.
>> I mean, I wouldn't say that. I I lean towards he's lying.
I I lean towards when he says, "Well, I had no idea and I've
never known up until somebody pointed out recently."
About the tattoo, I'm like, "Yeah, I don't believe that." I don't
know it for a fact. I don't know if I can say I know he's lying.
>> as a candidate to lie. Like I'm not Listen, I'm just
I'm aware of political realities and so sometimes politicians
lie and sometimes that's the right move. Um you know,
it's a bit cynical, but that's the reality. Um but but he is
we know he's lying. We know for a fact that he's
>> Are politicians that lie disqualified? Like is this
more or less bad his lying than Joe Biden running for office
and saying he would not pardon his son
and then pardoning his son on the way Like I think that is a
more deliberate lie, no?
>> That's like lying specifically about what he would do
with the office they were giving him.
Platner is not doing that kind of lie.
As long as Hutch could admit that Joe Biden is a far more egregious
and disgusting liar than Grant Platner,
which I feel like he'd have a hard time
Or that Biden would only run for a single term. Yeah. Like as
long as you're willing to admit that Joe Biden is a far more
disgusting and egregious liar than Grant Platner. And that on
moral grounds a skull and crossbones, a Totenkopf, okay? A Totenkopf
tattoo is far less egregious than aiding and abetting the genocide
in Gaza. So, realistically on on principal grounds, you also
don't really oppose Gramsci on there. As long as you're willing
to accept all of these things, then we're like totally fine,
right? Like like Hutch really doesn't have this standard, which
is fine. People misunderstand their own standards all the time.
But as long as he can admit these things if he was like presented
them directly,
then I guess I'd be fine with some of his positions, but >> The
Reddit posts or whatever. I don't really care about the Reddit
posts too much. I think, you know, I'm a little concerned about
how women voters in Maine are going to feel when there are going
to be
flooding the airwaves in Maine highlighting his more problematic
Reddit posts specifically about women. I I do worry about that,
but >> Officer Nasty, thank you for the four months. Appreciate
it, man. >> exclude former internet like edgy people from
running for office. Certainly not in this day and age. But we
know he's lying about the the tattoo. I mean,
I find the story believable that he got drunk in Croatia. I do
find that believable, frankly.
There is nothing in his old Reddit posts that I've seen yet that
indicate he has actual not Nazi ideology.
Okay. It's also possible to me
>> Stalin's law, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, man. >> that he knew what the tattoo was, but was getting
it to to
to evoke feelings of like to to to to present as like scary.
Like maybe the point was like that they were so dead they were
like this deadly group of like
uh brothers.
You know, there's there's lots of ways that you can explain the
tattoo uh uh uh that doesn't that doesn't indicate that doesn't
like suggest that he's an actual Nazi, you know, like genuinely.
I just haven't seen any of his messages
line up with that. That That doesn't mean that it's
still not great um or or you know, that it isn't not great. But
it Uh, you know, what is completely
unbelievable is the idea that he only found out
just before the story dropped. That is just I If you believe
that, you are a mark, okay?
Rattle with $5. The biggest problem with Platner is not the mistakes
he's made, it's the lying, it's him playing victim and blaming
everyone else in false integrity. Yep.
>> Blaming the I just This also gets me cuz I do think
I could understand having this argument, okay?
I just don't understand Hutch having this argument.
That's all. I I could get It's like this guy is a narcissist
who self-victimizes every time someone calls him out for his
And Hutch is like, "Yeah, that's the worst thing ever." I think
that's That is like the worst thing you could say about a person.
Destiny, these people are being mean to >> uh media scrutiny
and the scrutiny >> with that [__] bro. Come
on, man. >> party and the scrutiny from Republicans
who are all just simply doing their jobs by looking into his
past and background.
Blaming them
for his problems is just a really tough pill to swallow.
I just
>> Dude, no. No, come on. >> Democratic party and
the scrutiny from
who are all just simply doing their jobs by looking into his
past and background.
Blaming them
for his problems is
>> There is just no Dude.
It's actually crazy, right? It's actually crazy. >> really
tough pill to swallow.
>> Is it a tough pill to swallow?
Is it? Are you sure? >> I just I frankly drives me insane.
Not their fault you have really questionable
if Hutch loves all these, you political operatives who are doing
opposition research on Grant Platner, WHAT'S HIS PROBLEM WITH
ME? WHAT DID I DO TO THIS >> They get everybody in on all
this kind of manosphere nonsense. This idea >> Just doing
their job, check. It's not their fault. It's not the people reporting
on it who are at fault. It's the person with the bad judgment,
bad behavior, check.
What? What? What? >> Yeah, that like >> You're supposed
to use your >> The the racist Reddit posts, I don't I don't
know. I I haven't poured through >> kind of um
to like use power over other people or to offend people, be mean
to people, that somehow that's manly. That's not. That's the
act of a coward. And I think it's important
it's important I mean it's a it's I don't know how to talk about
this cuz it's going to sound like I'm saying I do this on purpose,
but I don't. But like it is important to like have people who
can show that you look, you can be a tattooed, deep-voiced combat
veteran who makes a living on the sea. >> Also, he kind
of reeks of false
It's It's just I'm not just I'm not trying to do, you know, like
I don't know. It's just annoying. >> Also, go to therapy
and think that it is a virtue to show up for your neighbors and
care about other people. In fact, I think those two things go
completely hand in hand. They aren't separate. But we do have
this vision of masculinity in our society right now, which kind
of makes one seem like >> It's like, bro.
You don't try to be a good person?
[__] Every good person tries to be a good person.
That's what makes them a good person. It's just like, yeah, it's
like a humble brag. Like, oh, you know, I'm just I'm not doing
it for, you know, I I just do it. I just do without thinking.
You know, like, but this [__] Everybody that tries
to be a good person has to make effort to be a good person. That's
not That's what makes good people good
>> Is this where we're Yeah, we're going to quibble over
this one? >> It It takes work. It takes dis- discipline.
It takes humility and respect and and principles and uh whatever.
>> If you're this way, you're supposed to be like hardened
and shut off from the world and angry. And >> Did you use
>> To be honest, I just don't like the guy. He gives me
bad vibes. I would vote for him over an R. I feel like you also
just don't like I don't. I don't. I I don't I don't. I don't.
I don't pretend to like him. I don't like him. I don't He gives
me about 50 different red flags.
You know, if I met him at a party and he talked the way that
he talks, I would I find an excuse to walk away. I just don't
like his vibes. I just don't like >> used to think that?
>> yeah. I mean, I spent years I mean >> I think
we all know what his vibes are, right? It's the vibe is Hassan
likes this guy. That's That's literally the vibe. If Hassan was
absent in this equation, Hutch got into politics being a Bernie
bro, this guy got endorsed and introduced to the world as as
a Bernie Sanders acolyte, Hutch would have loved this guy. It's
entirely about Hassan. I don't know why he pretends otherwise.
Embarrassing. >> I was when I was
when I kind of was in my darkest moments after my my military
service, I mean, I was extremely isolated.
I was very alone.
>> I did not feel connected to people. >> I mean,
I also like to to be Truthfully, I mean, I also like have have
sympathy for him. I mean, he's not asking for my sympathy, but
you know,
it's not that I I expect him to be this like perfect human being
or anything and you know, what his experience does sound difficult
and I don't just like dismiss >> I was emotionally
just fully unavailable. I mean, I didn't even I and I felt that
like if I opened up to people, if people saw my weaknesses, they
would like judge >> Like he does sound genuinely sound
like he has like some self-awareness
that is authentic to me. >> me for it. And so, the best
thing to do is kind of put on this sort of tough guy >> I'd
respect Hutch so much more if he at least attacked Planer for
his history with Blackwater. It's not even Blackwater. It's like
some of the interviews he's given. I got sent like an interview
he did. And it's like, dude, this guy straight up loved people.
Like any And he almost can't hide it in interviews. Like he could
he could lie about a lot, but what he can't lie about is his
love for for ending HUMAN LIFE.
>> I SWEAR THAT'S LIKE THE ONLY thing he can't lie about.
And that's That's the weird thing is nobody's really focused
in on that cuz I'm pretty sure
for Republicans they're like, we can't focus on that cuz this
sounds awesome. Like he's going to win all Republican men in
Maine if they focus on that. So they won't do that, right? But
I think that is like unironically probably the thing you could
criticize him for. >> And that was the unhappiest I've
ever
I've never been more lonely. I've never been more >> And it's
frustrating because Sorry, I'm pausing a lot. It's frustrating
because I think this message is really important for men right
now. I I just think he's an imperfect vessel of this of this
kind of message. But I think he's speaking a language that is
that is um useful in the times that we live in right now. The
way he talks about
the isolation that his kind of his own kind of toxic masculinity
um caused him and like that pain. I I I think that that's an
an effective
useful, important message for
I Here's the thing, and I'm getting like the opposite vibe of
Hutch.
feel like that's the lie to me.
The idea that he's [__] up by his tours and stuff.
I actually That's the thing that's maybe the spookiest part about
him to me.
I don't think he's [__] up by the tours. I think
he's not [__] up by a bunch of people. That's like
the spooky thing to me, man. I'm not joking. That is like the
the crazy weird thing to me is I think this guy is straight up
like not worried at all. Like he he has never lost a wink of
sleep over people. Is private security toxic masculinity? Well,
private military like paramilitary organizations, are probably
up toxic masculinity, probably.
>> a lot of men to hear right now. So, if there's any silver
linings about Platner being this guy who's getting this national
attention, I do think there are some kernels of like good stuff
kind of tucked away in the stuff that he says.
And it was only after
moving back to my hometown, quite
getting very engaged in my community, and then being willing
to start like opening up to people and making myself vulnerable,
that resulted in a level of fulfillment and happiness that I
never could have imagined. And that really got me to where I've
been for the past few years, which has been living a very, very
pleasant life. >> You have a generation of men like you
whose formative experiences
>> He's incredibly flawed messenger, but how are you going
to get this kind of message from someone who isn't incredibly
flawed? I take your point. I get the sense that
>> He's still a little undercooked. You know what it reminds
me of?
Anybody who's in recovery
knows what I'm talking about.
It reminds me of Okay, so like in NA and AA, right? Especially
after you get a few years,
you know, you get 3 years clean, 4 years clean, 5 years clean.
What happens a lot in recovery is people will come in with like
30 days of recovery,
and they'll be they'll share in meetings, and they'll talk about
like profound life lessons and, you know, like spiritual principles
and you know, like they'll give advice
to people for like how to do recovery.
And it's like kind of like a meme in recovery spaces. It's like
and and the people with like a little bit of time,
you're kind of in your you're you're kind of in your head thinking
like, oh, bless your heart, you know. You you probably shouldn't
be like talking too much in the early stages of recovery. You
should probably do more listening. That's kind of like And in
some meetings they're a lot more hardcore about it than others.
Like some meetings they'll just they have like rule like you're
not allowed to talk unless you have like a year's clean time.
That's kind of like not the norm, but it kind of reminds me of
that. Like he's just, you know, I do think he's
I do think he's he sounds like he's on a better path in his life,
but he's a little just like undercooked, I think. >> Comparing
PTSD from war to him being a
Yeah, he is.
I will say I just
with Platner, my concerns aren't really about him being like
a so much. It's more about
like the degree to which I'm just being manipulated by an intelligent